so mediaite reports Twitter employees
explode over musk deal cue the layoffs
maybe I bet a lot of these people are
going to quit Daniel Sullivan says the
reaction from Twitter employees on team
blind an app that allows people at
different companies to post anonymously
is something to behold here's one so
we've got an angry triggered billionaire
going to own us who's looking for
vengeance the worst Financial Market in
years hiring freezes everywhere Q4 is
looking great
Twitter employees heard the news the
latest development in musk's potential
purchase while they were in a meeting
discussing the company's goals in 2023
living the plot of succession is effing
exhausting rum and chattery Twitter's
director of machine learning ethics
transparency accountability tweeted in
reaction to the musk news
Daniel Sullivan said this Twitter
employee sums up what I'm hearing from
folks inside the company today and uh
that's too bad
E.J Simpson says I encourage every
Twitter employee to go outside and take
a walk yes never boring over here yeah
congratulations Twitter employees you
know it's just the weirdest thing the
cult is the weirdest thing to me you
know they they just
in order to be in this cult you have to
not read the news ever
and so we'll get into this a little bit
but I was talking about BLM and Kanye
West earlier on my other show and if you
look at Democrats or if you look at 18
to 35 year olds they have tremendous net
support for BLM and then you look at
every other demographic and it's just
like underwater independent voters it's
net a negative 12 net support uh only
Democrats support them and I'm like it's
the perfect example these people are
freaking out because the only way the
cult exists is that they they isolate
people from information the only reason
why these young people support BLM is
because they don't read the news they're
more subject driven and not object
driven so you get older you start
focusing more on your family you start
reading the news and seeing what's going
on in the world and you say oh okay
here's what's happening when you're
younger you're like what are my friends
doing what are my friends talking about
and your friends will just all repeat
whatever lies are filtered to them this
is obviously why these people are in
particular well they're losing their
minds over this the cult is going to
implode without Twitter I mean they
needed they have Tumblr I guess you know
but I don't know how much that how how
much that's going to do for them well
it's funny watching these people just
switch like uh immediately the same
people saying oh Twitter's a private
company they could do whatever they want
you you every yeah
proposals from the White House right uh
calling to um censor the internet yeah
AI Bill of Rights yeah that's what they
came out with uh the hill did an article
on this today was it Democrats uh the
white house so I'm guessing yes
whoever's whoever works there who really
knows this is basically you can't you
can't get banned yeah yeah you have the
right to a person as opposed to an
algorithm like that it's just a list
it's a proposal you know that's going to
go through well it's funny how it
switches like almost immediately yeah
yeah our people aren't in charge anymore
it happened today exactly so obviously a
lot of people
um at Twitter will be scrambling with
this news today according to the New
York Post uh 68 of Twitter employees
disapprove of musk and his vision for
Twitter and for what he sees for the
company that especially wants to make
sure that people are going to be at uh
the workplace and not just doing all the
work at home but but it's not just
Twitter employees that are going to be
scrambling here it's also a lot of
government officials who are now going
to be like okay now we have to prevent
this from happening because once you
open the floodgates of free speech you
have the potential of really making the
world a better place you have the
potential of exposing a lot of sinister
nefarious things in our existence that
could be stopped through transparency
and accountability the government is
deathly afraid of this and I I could
imagine I could see new rules new
regulations when it comes to social
media as already they have a lot of
secret orders they have a lot of secret
actions that they take part in as we
recently learned from Alex Berenson that
they are the ones the federal government
the White House ordering the censorship
of political voices of scientists of
Doctors medical professionals and even
memers and individuals who of course do
parody accounts of Dr fauci have all had
their accounts shut down because the
federal government and the Biden
Administration said no we can't allow
this which is absolutely crazy they're
not going to be able to censor those New
York posts articles well Elon Musk also
a couple days ago was interacting with
the CEO of Rumble and he was showing
interest in working with Rumble before
this major acquisition of Twitter which
he now has announced as of today so
there's also that as well there is
something called the Twitter trusted
partnership in Twitter partner support
portal that allows the government to
issue censorship orders Twitter agreed
to comply with this to avoid a
regulatory oversight there's a wow
there's an art this was a few years ago
where this happened and it was there's
one newspaper that covered it because
nobody's going to talk about that it was
the NC Daily Gazette
the question I guess is Will these woke
people stay on Twitter
because their argument is if Elon buys
Twitter we're leaving it's like oh yeah
where where are you going where you're
going to go Facebook I mean if it goes
they're going to go to gab yeah they go
somewhere else I mean that the um Amazon
and Google will allow it unlike with the
Parlor right right
um yeah but mastodon's been around for a
while and it's got It's like it's very
very leftist version of Twitter it's so
woke that when um who's that guy who
played that that that annoying kid on
Star Trek that everybody will Will
Wheaton there you go yeah yeah even when
he left Twitter and went there they
banned him oh my God that's how that's
how woke and far left there they were
like no Will Wheaton you're a fascist
and he's like an annoying liberal dude
so I mean they tried it didn't work yeah
I think it's going to be a dramatic
shift there's one dude from NBC who's
claiming this is funny this tweet where
he's like now that they're going private
the rules can be whatever they want and
it's just like you've literally been
advocating for that the whole time
that's literally what they do but what
they're really showing is that they are
terrified they have lost control of the
narrative machine and the crazy thing
about it is Elon Musk isn't even
proposing to go into Twitter and ban
left ban the left this is what they're
arguing they're like Trump's gonna uh
they're they're like elon's gonna be
de-platforming people and banning
leftists it's like literally the
opposite of everything is advocated for
it yeah it is not going to do that at
all he wants to bring the people back
who've been unfairly banned well that's
the problem I guess the left is like
when we get power we will destroy you
and when the right gets power they're
like no no we'll be fair yeah we'll do
what you want yeah we'll we'll leave it
how dare you
well even in the disclosures of Elon
musk's test text messages there's one
conversation he had with an anonymous
Twitter employee that's not named
because of the quote sensitive nature of
the conversation the sensitive nature of
this conversation was quote how to
navigate how to let right Wingers back
on Twitter so so this is this is an
official text message that was happening
between Elon Musk and an employee at
Twitter that's that's Anonymous that's
that's pretty big
um I could send you the the copy of it
right now or I could just tweet it out
right now but the DMS and and the
private messages some of them are leaked
and people could read them online and
they really do tell a very interesting
tale of what's Happening behind the
scenes here we need to get a a video
ready of like Trump suiting up like
putting his shoes on and then walking
and straightening his tie he's like I'm
back I'm that's all I care about you
know bring Trump back because there were
so many journalists when he got banned
there were these threads where
journalists were like I would have to
have my phone on alert because it was my
job and so I would get an alert at three
in the morning they'd like my boss would
be calling me being like Trump tweeted
write it up and they'd be like it's
raining in the morning this is one of
the reasons I think so many journalists
probably hated Trump because he would
tweet at like 2 A.M yeah they'd have to
wake up and then be like write the story
like Trump says something about North
Korea I don't know what's going on and
then everybody's like I wish the guy was
would just play ball and just do what
he's told instead he
pisses off all these journalists so they
just write lies about him endlessly
I think a lot of Twitter is a consensus
between the Bots between the bands of
the right wing people
um it's it's about
finding consensus so when people who
aren't that same thing with you know you
have the media you have Hollywood you
have big Tech you have uh the the
corporate press you have the the the
government the career politicians you
have socialism everywhere it's
everywhere and I think a lot of that is
about consensus and it's so when
somebody who's maybe an armchair you
know they vote you know so they're going
to go they're going to research and
they're going to find everybody thinks
this way
nobody thinks that way so that way must
be bad you know so that's that's my idea
is that they use Twitter kind of as a
machine for consensus I mean it'll be
interesting to see what happens with
these elections coming up in November uh
with Elon Musk If he if he takes over by
then and I'm already getting messages I
was scrolling through Facebook today uh
notifications and they were saying well
we're gonna you know there's gonna be I
didn't read through all of it but it
seemed like they were priming you to be
ready for censored content when the
election comes up and so it's like
they're already sending us warnings like
there's going there's something's coming
yeah Josie you're definitely right and I
would even go further absolutely big
Tech social media is used as a tool not
just for consensus but for manipulation
and there are Bots there's a lot of bots
there's a lot of sock puppet accounts
there's a lot of government officials
the Israeli government even announced
this 15 years ago that they're hiring
individuals to set consensus online to
of course spread the messaging that's
more favorable towards their government
if you think the US government is not
doing this if you think the Chinese
government and the Russian government is
not doing this you're absolutely kidding
yourself and there's a lot of bots it's
estimated according through a lot of uh
accounting that that you know a lot of
the most popular accounts have the most
amount of bots since Bots following
those accounts like Biden is expected
According to some estimates having at
least 49.3 percent of his entire Twitter
followers to be Bots to be fake so so
when you look at the consensus and when
you look at what people really think and
you look at the reality on Twitter it's
a totally different reality uh there's a
Quincy poll showing how the majority of
Americans 50 57 percent of them want
negotiations want to end the war in
Ukraine as soon as possible but that
wasn't reflected in the Elon Musk poll
that he did asking around the similar
question of of Peace in Ukraine so
what's really going on here obviously
there's a lot of manipulation behind the
scene that we don't even know about war
is very profitable so incredibly
profitable so we have
a recession you know so they're not
fixing that they're making it worse how
could they fix it with a snap of a
fingers War thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there